[Music]
ricardo garcia lopez has finally left
the world of work behind him but he's
had little time to enjoy his retirement
a year ago he was unexpectedly elected
mayor so he buckled down and got to work
piazza the community he serves is still
grappling with a mountain of debt left
over from the previous administration's
risky infrastructure projects
fundamentally
we have a huge debt problem our
infrastructure is crumbling because we
can't afford the upkeep
or we never managed to finish the
project in the first place like with the
water treatment plant
pios used to just be a small village
with 400 residents
then there was a building boom new
development sprang up with enough living
space for 25 000 people
but only 4 000 moved in
pios built a cultural center swimming
pool and a water treatment facility that
was supposed to be paid for by the
developer
but they left the community 7 million
euros in debt
the spanish government provided a loan
but that only made things worse
the government lent us 5.4 million euros
we've been paying it back for five years
but now we owe 6 million euros we can't
even afford the interest the government
is charging us
is a member of the left-wing podemos
party they're looking to break ties with
spain's political past
lopez doesn't take a salary wants to
bring the water plant online and is
constantly looking for solutions for
pios's problems
but he can do little to solve the
problem of the village's crushing debt
that's why he and his colleagues are
looking for help
our party podemos is probably going to
call for a 5 billion euro assistance
fund from the european central bank in
order to fix the problem
if the spanish government can't afford
to help us then we'll have to ask europe
for help
lopez and his city council don't just
want money they're constantly looking
for ways to save money they've even
taken steps to use the town's drinking
water more efficiently and that's earned
him community support
he's doing all he can but if there isn't
any money there's not much you can do
the mayor and a city council member
spend their afternoons changing the
street lights both hope that residents
will follow their example and give
something back to the community but for
the moment it's just the two of them
you